le régime de ben ali vient de tomber le
leader islamiste rached ghannouchi est
accueilli en héros dans sa tunisie
natale après 20 ans d'exil
cet homme est associé aux frères
musulmans égyptiens et proches du régime
des ayatollahs en iran sont partis
politiques et narda qui veut dire
renaissance autrefois interdits et
maintenant réhabilité ils occupent
depuis une place centrale dans la
politique tunisienne
le parti islamiste détient encore
aujourd'hui un bloc de 54 sièges sur 217
un nombre suffisant pour contrôler
l'assemblée avec l'aide de partis
radicaux ghannouchi est actuellement le
président du parlement troisième poste
en importance dans le pays
si ils promettent ils disent dieu fera
en sorte qu'on va réussir si jamais on
réussit pas et on réussit pas
généralement ils disent dieu n'a pas
voulu
allard alpes youssef seddik philosophes
anthropologues grand spécialiste de
l'islam n'est pas tendre à l'égard des
élus du parti ennahda à son avis ils ont
utilisé la religion pour masquer leur et
compétences au niveau de
l'administration de la gestion des
affaires ils sont l'ul son lieu pendant
dix ans ils n'ont pas fait un seul
chantier ils n'ont pas construit de
manière réussie une seule banque
une seule université il accuse également
les dirigeants tunisien actuel de se
livrer à la corruption
alors comment expliquer qu'il soit
encore populaire ce que les gens même
s'ils n'ont plus confiance dans des
dirigeants musulmans islamistes disons
comme nav
il continue à croire que l'islam et les
i dans le monde
il y a un peu partout dans le pays mais
surtout dans les régions frontalières de
la tunisie des cellules terroristes
toujours active qui menace ces groupes
ont ciblé des touristes étrangers dans
des attaques armées faisant des dizaines
de morts le musée du bardo à tunis ou
dans des hôtels de villégiature sur la
côte
il ya actuellement en tunisie des
mosquées fréquentées et financé par des
islamistes radicaux en octobre dernier
un imam d'une de ces mosquées a lancé un
appel à tuer des étrangers
il s'inspirait de la décapitation
récente d'un enseignant en france
pourtant cet imam n'a subi aucune
sanction judiciaire
les mosquées sont des lieux où la parole
est absolument incontrôlable
les autorités le ministre des affaires
religieuses ont beau dire que c'est
contrôler mais ce n'est pas contrôler
95% de ces gens-là de ces imams qui font
un congrès par semaine vendredi sans
désignera la santé signale même en
matière de religion
plus inquiétant encore un militant des
droits de l'homme
wajdi mawashi qui avait dénoncé l'imam
fanatiques à lui été condamné à une
peine de deux ans de prison
c'est une épée de damoclès qui pèse
toujours sur les têtes et personne qui
s'exprime d'une manière qui ne convient
pas aux normes sociales ou politiques
il ya eu beaucoup d'appels à la haine à
la violence et donc il fallait mettre
fin à cela
et au lieu de cela le procureur n'ouvre
pas d'enquêté après avoir fait carrière
dans les universités de france
l'islamologue et philosophe et youssef
seddik est rentré dans son pays
au lendemain de la révolution il ya
encore un potentiel de violence à
attendre dans une usine je ne me sens
pas du tout capable d'être l'optimiste
qui pire est devant nous dix ans plus
tard cet intellectuel le constate avec
tristesse que les mouvements radicaux et
les partis conservateurs sont les plus
populaires dans sa patrie
[Musique]